[Music]
in news submitted by let's get it
hundreds lose their driving licenses
during Oktoberfest East cooter mayhem so
I guess in Germany they oktoberfest it's
a in this particular case it's gonna be
a sixteen to a festival where they
celebrate drink beer eat a lot of food
and stuff but I guess a total of four
hundred and fourteen people were caught
riding in a scooter while under the
influence and 254 lost their driving
licenses as a result according to a
police statement released on Monday in
32 cases police patrols intervened to
prevent drunk driving because I don't
know if you guys know this but if you
guys get drunk and you get on a nice
scooter technically DUI just imagine you
just keep scooting and you're like like
in the like traditional German like very
crazy yeah cuz I mean do you guys see a
lot of the East Cooter's are out like in
LA for a little bit over there were
there a lot of scooters when you're
living in downtown and ever and then
they leave them in the weirdest place
[ __ ] annoying places I'm like in an
alley with a bum jerking off and there's
a a scooter there yeah they're like
always in front of bars they're like on
the street in the street okay so does
that mean that if someone's
skateboarding then they can get a DUI I
don't know about scape I know that my
cycling I know I know but I know
bicycling that's a bicycling you're
driving you're drunk I think that's a
DUI - oh yeah biking yeah not gonna pay
no I think biking like on a like actual
like on the streets yeah I was gonna say
maybe it's because like if it's
considered something you can you're
supposed to ride on the streets he's now
bikes who you're supposed to be on the
street yeah you're supposed to yeah
it's not really a force in LA but in
Beverly Hills like I was in Beverly
Hills I went to the Santa Monica College
for a little bit and I was almost I was
I'm just you said that and then like a
cop pulled me over it's like Pete over
here and I was like for what yeah I'm
just riding my bike he's like you gotta
be a long scream like but everybody's
like on the light no one's giving me a
broad away that's dangerous he's like no
it's dangerous I know yeah you have to
ride too with the flow of traffic don't
write against that's scary because the
cars behind you yeah and I feel like
they'll swerve into you and it's like I
like going toward traffic but then
you're more of a hazard that way though
yes the reasoning is because like you
see incoming traffic and you might get
freaked out yourself that you might
actually right in front of them yeah and
then time that in the case of a
collision if you're riding against
traffic then you're actually ruled at
fault yeah oh that's right because your
head would be like a head-on kind of
thing yeah and you're going the wrong
ways it's not the way the road is
intended nice guy on a bicycle that
turned into a right turn so like a guy
was making a right and this [ __ ] would
drove into him and flew into his car
I know he was making a left and I was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing so he
was driving against traffic this way and
he was turning that way and he just hit
that car oh yeah and I was standing
there about to cross the street like
this guy's a did he did he flip over the
car he went off to the car yeah and he
was mad at the car there's a good amount
equal blame to go around a lot of these
situations yeah I heard that in the Bay
Area and Bay Area fans out there
please let us know the comments below
that the e scooters like they're so
annoyed of them that they actually throw
them over the edge because they would
ball over on like parked cars because
it's like really hilly up there so yeah
I just think our cars and I neither just
news everywhere they're cluttering up
the sidewalks and stuff so yeah there's
no regulation for him like they just
sort of introduced them always like well
we're just on a that's the story they
just dropped him off like these new IT
companies just like yeah I think that I
was watching that was like they're
interviewing the like CEOs of like some
I don't know if those lime or bird or
whatever in they're just like well you
know work we're really working on trying
to figure out how to make it less of a
nuisance I'm just like man your smug ass
is like just roll at him legs like we're
real sorry how much money they make
others probably a lot to bake in like
maintaining everything I know so to me I
just feel bad cuz it's a lot of money
just being thrown out like a dog to star
in the sixties 15 cents per like minute
oh yeah so pretty where did you where
did you ride one it usually like any
other beaches they have known like now
they're like they're everywhere the
great city so yeah I mean I see him
around I've never jumped on one though
like we should all just border one we
should all just do it yeah I'm down do
one-handed right yeah you know the crazy
thing is though like some of the people
at the hospital we're trying to guess
what happened to me like I was going to
look at my x-rays like the dude the dude
was like oh let me guess what happen to
you do you fall for one of those
motorized scooters I was like my gosh a
lot of those though my girlfriend works
in like a like a hospital and she's like
yo theama bird accidents we've got her
bird vs. car accident spikelets aw kid
idiot and I saw it in his eyes cuz he's
like I actually don't know how to break
this made the decision it to jump oh but
he did it behind like the sign at my
apartment complex so that no one would
see him but I was turned against my
barber so I saw his just like he jumped
like he jumped off so I saw him coming
as I waited for him he went behind the
side so that no one would see him
because he knew he's about to eat it he
just ate it and I was like bro I saw I
saw the hope that you'd be an actual kid
or is it like these things like parents
will give their kids like because you
need to have your driver's license
driver's license oh no no it's like
these kids they don't know like the
basic rules of like driving and they're
just treating it like a regular scooter
but if you're going like 15 miles per
hour
you are dealing with a population
problem so maybe it's kind of maybe
these companies are doing the Lord's
work you know the companies are actually
the Lord he's like hey I gotta fix this
this is a plague he releases the bird
trouble thing it just pops up you can't
get rid of it yeah South Park episode Oh
but yeah so what happened to me I was
writing of my motorcycle home from work
one day and I got hit by a car on the
freeway on the freeway uh yep they
didn't look it was yeah on the freeway
rush hour
I was lane splitting between the fast
lane and the passing lane oh good thing
it was rush hour huh right it's cool
yeah it's like it's well good the thing
is like as weird as it sounds everything
in my accident went right because like
yeah it was rush hour
I was lane splitting but also I don't
Lane split incredibly fast it's actually
one for all you and the comic wandering
in California lane splitting is
acceptable not only that but it's
actually safer to lane split than to
stay in a lane yeah and that's because
like yeah your eyes don't naturally look
for you see both cutting all around
anyway so you don't wanna be right
behind a car you'll be right behind
reitman right next to because it's very
easy to be Nexus on make eye contact
with them but they got their windows up
and they look over again they don't see
you cuz you want a few more feet back
and they think you're gone so they
merged into you actually Nelson when he
crashed is because he wasn't lane
splitting right didn't he like basically
I I try to ride out of speed to where
it's like I have a few seconds ahead of
me that I can react to it's like traffic
super heavy Travis go maybe 50 miles per
hour I'm going less than 20 and
basically a car right in front of me out
of nowhere jumps to the right just like
as I'm right behind it so I collided
with its passenger door I think my arm
clipped its mirror and broke there I got
lunch diagonally off of my bike flew
past one lane hit my back against a car
flip through the air a few times landed
back in
the lane I was initially next to rolled
on the ground slit for a bit as I'm
sliding else and I see my left palm go
in front of my visor but I felt like my
arm was behind me that's broken I just
like slid to a stop and I'm just sitting
there like also like people like start
surrounding me and like I'm just like
hey hey cool can you just like there's a
thing on my helmet can just push this
button because I had like my bluetooth
turned on and so it's like it was lose
low but there was just so much traffic
that was kind of overwhelming once I got
that off me I was cool
I was like I was laughing I was like
how's her else is Dave going doesn't
like laying there on the freeway people
stop and in like kind of yeah the cars
around you and she I incredibly lucky
like I I didn't move once I hit the
ground and luckily like yeah people have
been got other cars people stop their
cars in time and they were there like
directing traffic around me the person
who hit you stop - I assume so I never
interacted with the person oh that's him
being very nice I think that person
probably was just like I'm out of here
[Music]
exchange information or get his
information or her cops because again
like I didn't know for sure that they
had any information and so sorts of
weird crap happened so I didn't know
they actually officially got their
information until a week ago
oh where he goes like so you're
thoughtfully it just dipped no I didn't
I don't think they dipped because it's
please okay so when I thought they did
personally do wait I don't think they
could because traffic yeah yeah sued
congested that's why I figured they did
it they can slowly go away
surrounded and all the other yeah but if
they're ahead like they hit Devon and
they were slowly rolling this is though
there's so many witnesses then it would
have taken pictures yeah like I saw I
saw a hit-and-run like a truck like a
big rig clip like clip the whole side of
a car I didn't I didn't notice or didn't
care and kept going and so I was like
and I like follow like took a picture
there I cool sent that to the police cuz
I was like yeah that's not cool oh damn
that's nice yeah well I was getting on
the same for you as well just watched
and so I was like well I'm already going
the same direction that this one is so I
like took the I actually called the
police and I was as I was I took a
picture I was calling place I was like
hey I just read off the license plate
number because I was like this person
isn't stopping like they're not stopping
so then the paramedics came and they
just like lifted you and took you away
yeah took them awhile like it was point
two because I I was wearing this really
really nice jacket and like that's why I
dressed for the slide not the right
always wear your gear and spine
protectors don't mean crap where for
Jackie but like that jacket was crazy
expensive I was just like like when the
paramedics like all right just so you
know we're gonna try to take like your
jacket off me but we might have to cut
it off you I was like let's try just do
I like it literally context context how
much is this jacket yeah this jacket is
between 400 and 600 dollars does it have
armor and everything is that it has
place for armor doesn't have a built-in
I like that you like that jacket it was
like full leather it was just like it's
a riding jacket yeah it's like this wax
like hide it's a really good writing job
but it saved your skin Oh 1,000% like I
could send you guys the pictures to
throw in the videos if you want yeah
let's do it like it's crazy cuz you will
look at the jacket it doesn't look like
what happened to me happened like it's
hard to actually track the fact that
what a good brand deal right there it is
roland Sands
you should send this video to him be
like yo thanks for the sponsorship
thanks for thanks for keeping him safe
I'm one person like with that though
because it's like guaranteed I would not
have been as okay physically as I was if
I wasn't in the gear that was as well as
all the different circumstances that
went right like people stopping in time
cuz the the crazy thing too is I thought
about it as like me getting eject off
the bike honestly probably saved my life
because I'm just looking right into it
yeah because if I if I had just went
down right there I would have been
immediately under someone's tires the
same for even like when I got launched
and I hit the side of somebody else's
car like if I landed in front of their
car I would've been under their tires
like you know I hear this story and it's
all serious but sometimes I like think
about it as like Scott Pilgrim and then
you're like ping-pong hang on it was all
like real time and I was just super calm
throughout like the moment I got ejected
from my bike I saw like my feet and I
saw my bike in the car legs getting
further anime sequence bro oh my god for
this ride I just like wit lip oh wait
let's just count what happens I hit a
car through the air do you think that
your stunts you don't know he's a
stuntman
do you think it's not work helped you go
limp with that 100% cuz I asked you
about that I was like wasn't the
hospitals like so this people's like
natural tendencies like go limp during
it they're like no people stiffen up
they try to fight it and I was like but
literally in my head I was just like as
I'm in the air me I was like oh I'm in
for the ride and like the thing is like
when you take like a car hit or when you
like yeah jump out of a car literally
it's basically you you either hit try to
hit a certain position but then the
second that you're getting hit or you're
in the air you're there for the ride you
just have to go with you can't buy the
momentum otherwise that's when you break
more stuff I mean that's what I heard
it's just like if if if you are in a
situation like of an accident like you
do want to go limp just because if you
do fight it you end up injuring yourself
more yeah cuz like that's the crazy
thing is like cuz you have me realizing
that my arm may have hit their mirror
and that's when it broke Wow
like because that's the only time my
body was stiff and that's just because
since I applied the brakes right there
for the split second my like when you
apply the front brakes the front of your
bike dips down so you're pushing against
there's tension right there and so I'm
pretty sure like they caught my arm
broken in half thank you guys but no
yeah it was it was a trip
[Music]
you